ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show it is Tim Dylan we are here
from our new studio which is a work in
[ __ ] progress keep your mouth shut
keep your criticisms down you there's no
such thing as constructive criticism
from any of you so shut up Roger Deakins
what's the chime man he can who the hell
is that
he's one of most famous cinematographers
in the world shut up you haven't been
introduced
they know me Ray's been in LA three days
walking around telling everybody how
Hollywood works okay we're here in the
new studio from an undisclosed location
so none of you [ __ ] people get cute
and [ __ ] show up and we're very
excited to be doing video because I know
it's very important for the people on
YouTube who get this show absolutely for
free who pay nothing they demand video
and then you're gonna but they're not
gonna like you're getting a yachtie back
I like the background yeah I wanna
listen it's all gonna it's all coming
together it's all coming together folks
okay as Ray said once during what the
best bomb I've ever seen was Ray in a
winery in Cape May New Jersey
do you remember knives right yeah West
Cape May New Jersey thank you for
clarifying West Cape May New Jersey a
fan of this show yeah had booked us they
booked me it explicably yeah he wanted
us to come down to do a show we thought
potentially there'd be fans of the
podcast right in Cape May New Jersey not
only was that not the case the room was
like older wine people it trashy though
trashy but not not our kind of trashy
not our fan right nobody that would
enjoy this Billy Joel fans more right
right Billy Joel fans right but but like
turn on him because he has the support
of trumpet yeah those are the types of
people you write write a song about
Trump [ __ ] remake piano man about Trump
you [ __ ] like they like the idea of
breeze Springsteen until he writes a
song about a cop getting shot yeah I
a cop shooting a black guy they don't
like that they listen to you know born
in the USA and think it's like the
biggest Pro America song in the world
yeah
they don't like 41 shots yeah let me
tell you right now I saw Bruce
Springsteen amazing with the best
concerts at the Madison Square Garden
East Reeb and 1999 with my friends Aunt
Deb and Deb took us and he did that so
41 shots about amadou diallo okay boy
did that cool the room boy did that cool
the room everybody was really into it
and then he was like full-on shots and
you could tell people in this walking
milling around going to get see gonna
have a cigarette yeah I was just
reaching for as well yeah and it's like
you know the people like there was no
course for them to sing now so they were
just like he had it comin supposed to do
easy so those are the types of people in
Cape May New Jersey and then we [ __ ]
go out right you know and you went up
and you had an epic bomb you started out
talking about and that's really I ripped
something and they went well well no you
you're right you had one great riff it
was a sentence and it really went well
do you remember what it was I don't I'm
leaving if that perhaps I don't know
whatever it was it was instantly
pleasing to that they were like indeed
when they laughed and then you made a
joke about heroin yeah I've been doing
this bit about you know it's not heavy
thing is I love the bit it's just about
heroin addicts like you know at least
they can make new friends in their 30s I
love that bit it's a good bit thank you
now the people at Cape met I guess their
kids are just dropping like flies right
those are the stuff I do heroin jokes
now but now it's gone the other way
we're even the parents of the kids who
died don't care any more than like
charade did that and they they turned on
him they so yelling like move on move on
right they're like move on move on and
then you dug deeper and deeper and then
he got to a point we go listen to me you
can't just say you're brought up heroin
your fat we hate you when you looked at
them anyone and so all coming together
for
it's all coming together and then one of
the greatest things ever you started
going into this bit about feminism
alright and rage is a progressive guy he
doesn't appear progressive he doesn't
sound progressive in many progressive
people wish you would just not say
anything just go away you know you think
you think they're mad at Romans
endorsement what about you know so
here's like I lost Marianne Williamson I
love if you married Marianne but so Ray
then he does have been about feminism
where the basic gist of the bid is you
go you can't just say hey like rights
don't work explain the bit but it's like
you know it's the one basically I was
friend from the island who's talking
about it was basically like basically
hey like we you know we gave you the
right to vote all right and you're like
that's not a right word yeah that's not
our rights work you can't turn around
and one of my favorite lines in the bit
which is just an aggressive line yeah is
you go we we stop fisting you on the
subway and so they just a group an older
crowd of wine drunks just hear him
they're not listening anymore to every
word and every nuance if they ever were
so they just hear you talking about
fisting on the subway right and then
I've never heard this in any comedy show
I've done and it's hilarious a loud
course of booze filled with this
literally they went get off get off get
off get off
guitar into get off and he then sat down
he finished up and sat down but it was
an epic bomb in the way that it was so
much more entertaining than most
people's specials now that's the problem
with comedies it's one of the least
entertaining things you could put your
put you could focus your eyes on
literally anything is funnier literally
anything people look I ever knew special
no one cares I mean good good for you
we're proud of you but not I mean it's
just not I mean no one's even putting
themselves out there is it's so much of
just like it's the kindest
it's such milquetoast Miller Road yeah
like what are we doing here right I mean
look Chappelle I love it but it's it's a
certain level of like I know I'm gonna
be doing the controversial thing right
now yeah I mean look it's cliche we
talked about someone I'm a Carlin guy I
go back it it was like he had a point he
was making a point he wasn't holding
back but there was there was a
construction of the of the joke that was
young intricate it was funny but you
know he but he was he's also like
conveying he's not Chomsky but he wasn't
Chappelle's doing that tell no she pal
is yeah it just feels a little more like
I feel like Carlin was trying to be like
but he also wasn't dealing with this
world culture [ __ ] whatever it is it's
just like nobody it's rare that we need
an hour from anyone unless they are
Chappelle right unless you're a legend
it's like tough tanita so it's like when
I watched that bomb and I put on
Instagram and people are like they're
invested in it because they're watching
something happen that what's interesting
about is like you don't know which ways
it's gonna go yeah Wow what's happening
right and with the comedy special you
know it's relatively good because that's
why it people somebody put it out right
right it's part of the problem is that
so many comedy fans it's not their fault
yeah we love them but like they want a
lot of timing like the edge of your
stuff or whatever like you're dealing
with that was wrong because you're
dealing people who like why am I even
watching this right what am i watching
maniac like that that level of just kind
of well yeah I mean we took register
raising they're like he's here he's
visiting we go down to to Nobu in Malibu
which is a sushi obviously a hot spot in
Malibu right on the water beautiful we
don't have reservations right go in
we're like do you have anything for two
they go yeah the sushi bar like face
face the wall you to face the wall
logics the rapper is walking out of
there I would not even even know who he
isn't old right number one he's white
and I know that he says the N word a lot
because he has a black parent god bless
him but it's your white so whatever but
I get it and he walks out like you know
and I'm like God good for him
and then he wasn't saying the n-word in
noble I'm just saying I've noticed that
you know he has that lice that was you
and I don't know it was me that was me
and we go in there and and ray first of
all it's no longer sunset it's dark you
can't see anything
no booze like infested with celebrities
and other people that don't want to be
like filmed ray does the craziest thing
I've ever seen in my life
he swivels around in the chair at the
sushi bar which by the way they put us
into sushi bar to face the wall so that
nobody would have to see us eating
forbidden fish cuz you know what sushi
is you slurp it with your fingers yeah
and nobody nobody needs to see ray or
myself playing with soy sauce you know
so they go face the wall he turns around
with his phone and starts filming the
restaurants it's absolutely true you
know that's why you're laughing say it's
a [ __ ] Horror Show first of all where
we're conspicuous in there already I'm
not a low profile keep it low keep it
low he turns out with his phone and he's
our driver and I go what the [ __ ] are
you doing I say you can't do this this
is crazy gonna try to tell everyone what
happened as a preface you've taken me
very nice restaurant I've never you know
you've never done this before I may be
the famous me lost your mind people you
had a moment of temporary insanity with
this I was only thinking about my
girlfriend Lucy okay that's sweet but
she's like shoot them to film a
restaurant magic is I understand that
there's regular people I think if it
would have been wrong in a sizzler which
we were in earlier next to the fat store
if you took out a phone in a sizzler and
did that it would be also wrong and
probably criminal architecture I
understand that a man such as yourself
should not be filming people and arrest
it was a picture was filming not a
documentary I wasn't trying to get like
some I wouldn't try to do some round and
pedophilia documentary in Nobu I'm just
[ __ ] trying like you know get like
show her the woods very nice here I
understand what you're trying to do but
it was a moment of temporary session you
were completely insane I forgot about
this place be if we mean you could just
walk in because we've talked about it
before nice restaurants are the only
thing that can't legally keep us out
right
that's why food is our only luxury we've
discussed this before people say why do
you like nice redwood then you let me in
your Country Club with that and I won't
be as fat I can't go anywhere else I
can't get on someone's jet
I can't just Walsh in to bel-air and
walk through the gates and enjoy myself
the only thing that so far legally they
cannot stop me and you from doing is
going to a nice restaurant it is the
only luxury for the poor I get beaten up
on fatty I'm not that positive fat
activist I get it it's bad for you of
cause diabetes I know everybody's trying
to be better out there maybe some people
aren't but whatever none of us are happy
being fat that's the other thing how
many people are actually happy being fat
not a lot you know some people are can
tend to be slobs sure but like this
whole idea that there's a lot of people
being like I'm fat and deal with it it's
just not how it's gross I mean the
millionaire's are doing it but not
people on a bus nobody on a public bus
is thrilled to be a fat ass yeah no one
wants it nobody wants nobody who's poor
and fat is like look at this [ __ ] it's
called confidence no no one's doing that
in a Walmart what it is is millionaires
who are like just gonna put it out there
and make money doing it well it's really
also keep eating our poison right you
know it's like hey you gonna put down
that macaroni and cheese fatty yeah
swallow it yeah this is that like that
there's an interest in it whatever they
want you eating salad like who would the
dole corporation is not the biggest
consortium and [ __ ] bits about it we
were raised a lot of our generation and
it doesn't this doesn't justify
eating this [ __ ] now and it doesn't
justify not changing your life but our
and I've said it before and I say it
onstage our boomer parents fed us poison
we were the fast food generation right
in a way that kids growing up today are
not I mean we were we were people at
birthday parties in fast food places are
there are formative years well before
even supersize me which was right there
was a big turning point where they
started to at least show they try with
it was eat there was a level of shame
we're like that we're gonna make sounds
more prominent and we're gonna try like
I was on that guy's podcast bar lock and
they didn't he to himself and no one can
remember that yeah he went out there and
he's like I've acted in a propensity but
you feel like as much as I didn't do
anything to fast food yeah there was
still a level of like yet you're still
gonna eat this stuff fatty but like I
they weren't even showing salad I mean
if kids don't even have them and then
like when they had a salad shaker yeah
there was like a shank
make sure you he's poor like you know
3/4 of his distraught but a guy that
says make this [ __ ] illegal or whatever
but I am saying when your kid and you
grow up in these environment eating this
type of food it is it is not good and I
feel like a lot of kids today aren't
because people are more educated now
right about food
they're more educated but it is a luxury
for the poor food is a luxury for poor
people it's the one thing you can do it
mean even even a nice Kraft macaroni and
cheese it's a nice shut up now you're
now you're going let's just use
McDonnell not gonna cosign that why I
what I'm saying
but butter it eat my butter what I'm
saying is stop stop talking about Kraft
macaroni and cheese jesus [ __ ] christ
my point is that even a poor person can
can wrangle enough money to go put a
stake in their throat wouldn't be like
steak and a baked potato in their throat
if there's no McDonald's be well know
that McDonald's really isn't a luxury ok
it's a necessity I guess for certain
people whatever but my point is that
that's why you will you go to Nobu that
can
keep us out they can't they can't you
know when we walk in here they can't go
excuse me you think us in a back room
and beat the [ __ ] out of us sure they
can't do that yet yet it's coming I'm
sure it's coming right they'll find a
way to lock it all that you've you've
been in LA now for three days what are
your what are your thoughts on the
geography on the area
what's your there is a tremendous amount
more horror than I anticipated I thought
I thought really the horror would be
that there's this kind of seamy
underbelly of this wealth like we like
the reason when you go to New York we're
like oh I guess he's rich people but
like it's a little shading and probably
you know doing some with strokes no like
you're literally driving through Black
Hawk Down to get to Hollywood there are
certain parts of LA where the apocalypse
has happened yeah it's happened there
are tent cities you have medieval living
situations in terms of like no no
[ __ ] bathrooms no running water and
then you have diseases coming back that
have been gone for years things like
dysentery that come from filthy living
conditions and I think our uber driver
said today to us before she went on a
rant about the Jews remember that she
goes the Beverly Hills she goes he's
owned by the Jews at all Jews I was like
okay she told us it was a hundred and
forty five thousand homeless people in
Los Angeles
I estimated a little bit lower when we
went to skid row yeah cuz ray just look
at his Skid Row is I'm thinking how
these people there's a few hundred
people helpless people helpless man
first of all we got to skid row we
rolled the window down and three people
emerge from a tent went ray and that's
when we had to leave because I said I
don't know how many people are very
specific families you're the only guy
that ate at Nobu that could have went to
skid row and also fit in there perfectly
absolutely perfectly but I mean how do
you fit
that problem it's hard yeah I mean you
have to I mean there's no projects here
which is whether they're right there are
probably there is public housing okay
but not like Tower comes there's a lot
of people I mean the idea of this is
problems with vertically placing cheap
housing or poor housing for the poor but
you know it seems so I'm just saying
there are pitfalls that you know to that
method of doing by the other day like
how else you gonna do it we have a
hundred forty five thousand people and
it's like how much worse is it zanten
see they talk about like how like oh
yeah like you might get mugged people
get mugged in the hallway because you
know the visibility and like the corners
and like and the kind of diffusion of
responsibility it happens when you live
in this big building and you're not
paying like your own rent I think yeah
yeah sure but like dysentery botulism
yeah that's occurred on the streets like
maybe we deal with that when we come to
it you know yeah those things are a lot
worse but what are some of the positives
other than the return of the diseases
the post-apocalyptic kind of hellscape
oh it's lovely I want move here there
are nice things about it I mean the way
they're unleashing things but let's not
spend too much time on the breakdown of
society right the fall of a civil
society in a fall of a social order
let's not spend an inordinate amount of
time on that when there are so many
positives is reality if you think if
you're gonna experience the end of the
world on the front line which these
people are why not do it in a place with
a nice climate it has a beautiful
climate it's wonderful that's what
people don't talk about when they talk
about our inability to house hundreds of
thousands of people who then [ __ ] on the
street right they don't mention that it
is a nice climate here honestly they
don't balance it out and go but
dysentery but plague is back but lovely
weather I'm living in a better place
than I was when we first did the podcast
yes I talk about I think I was talking
about frequently how I I might say now
I'm not saying it's good row where I was
living I'm not trying to but I live in a
windowless room which in the summer got
incredibly hot and
and just disgusting and plus I never
threw my garbage out so like would it be
worse to live on the street in Skid Row
maybe like on the you know again the
diseases and the micro bacteria but I
feel like yeah it's like it's like
camping in the fall it's nice know is
your living situation when I first met
you and in your driving situation I mean
you drove a car where the window was
broken the window it roll around and it
was broken and the first time I met you
so he there was no heat in the car and
he said we have to smoke cigarettes to
keep ourselves warm right and that's
when I kind of picked up the occasional
ciggy again side quit four years I quit
smoking cigarettes four years I was
actually still drinking and smoking pot
before I stopped smoking cigarettes
right I got rid of cigarettes and then I
met ray and it's not your fault yeah but
I met you and then driving back to Long
Island
you were like listen we don't have heat
in the car but here's what we can do we
can smoke cigarettes on the way back to
Long Island and I thought that was a
fair compromise and a good way to get
heat and then we would always go to that
taco bell/pizza hut or a diner right
talk about pizza from the tag Robo you
had the Taco Bell because that was it
was 3 a.m. there wasn't a lot open at
that point no and then we would sit in
the in the parking lot of the talk about
Pizza Hut and recap the evening right
nachos Bell Grande you've you know
what's crazy about this area to me is
that it gets a little worse even since
I've been here it just creeps in there's
a few more tents right a guy with a
shopping cart going down the block yeah
and it's more and more and you wonder
how long that takes until there's some
type of breaking point well I think
because we went to skid row but that was
like a second day but like on the way
from LAX it's just a Hollywood like
who's there in a nicer area it's even
worse because you're prepared for skid
row right and it's like and in the level
of like oh these are these people are
like I'd to bring its it's sad but like
just the kind of level of gradual horror
and decay
just think about a lot of people's kid
Rosie did seem happy there at look there
was a there was a there isn't and this
is just an observation I'm not saying
that don't you know be like I'm saying
the outward appearance of a lot of these
people was they were jubilant probably
didn't work I think they're getting a
buzz on a bit but it makes you think
about life it really does yeah you go
down skid Road suppose horrible
conditions ever and there are people
there that are dancing and they're happy
and then you meet people that live in
these big beautiful homes and they're
not that happy
we've usual [ __ ] Bernie Sanders and [ __ ]
all you people that think you just need
everything you can make do with less
you'll be fine let it go manage
expectations this is what your
expectations are killing you you expect
a good life stop that
enough of that you think about the yarn
today yacht you want how much is the gas
to fill it up right you didn't think
about that you don't think it's it's a
it's a burden you don't think about
right but my whole thing is be happy
with less you know what I mean but we've
tended to go the opposite route with
that over the years yeah but what a lot
of people argue that like poor people
are actually happier if you look at it
the rich are very unhappy it's like
which is like a comforting feeling to
accompanying expressly I'm not saying
that poor people are happy I'm saying I
went to skid row and I saw people there
that were happier than people that I
knew even if it was momentary right even
if it was induced by a substance sir I'm
not making a socio-political point I'm
just you gotta observe things right and
you can't crowd an ideology like if you
can't cram an ideology into every
observation you can't look at somebody
dancing in the street and go but I
better you know sometimes you just gotta
take it at face value and go yes this
gentleman would probably rather be in
another situation well however humans
are incredibly adaptable and you know
one thing I'll say for the people of
Skid Row I don't think they're gonna
drive down the Beverly Hills and
like you know lusting over that a big
part of its like about you know
comparative weltering apparently in the
ass I'm really thinking about the
Flamingo in the in the front yard though
you're understanding this is what it is
yeah you are not reaching the reach is
really what gets you the reaches would
get you part of our new motivational
programs new shirt will be printing yes
the reach is what gets you stay low stay
low to the ground yeah but it's almost
something not jumbo not everything about
like how blow surprised about was just
like horror
yeah we're just like a lot of that wait
now once we got close to that
Hollywood's I mean with the Malibu like
a lot of beautiful spots but a lot of it
was just like just the worst parts of
Long Island like I love I felt like the
Li II spread out over like a much wider
it's not funny
yeah like Long Island is funny right
because the people in Long Island are
[ __ ] right and that's what makes it
funny because they're [ __ ] and yet
somehow many of them have managed to
acquire things that they never should
have had and still aren't happy with and
maintain a sense of victimhood
they're always aggrieved party no matter
what happens they inherit houses they
complain about the taxes on the houses
they inherit it just never ends there
are always someone's always coming
trying to kill them ms-13 is always in
the window with a machete going at them
and the only personal change was Sean
Hannity Sean Hannity and his freedom
concert there's nothing better than
watching people in Long Island white
people who had a culture back when it
required some degree of like you know
boats and learning how to whatever and
like being a you know appreciating that
you lived by the sea in the ocean but
then once people traded that in for just
the suburban sloth of it all right there
are cultural Espina like Connecticut so
when white people have no culture they
start going to like country-western
bands they start pretending they're like
country-western so Sean Hannity used to
have these freedom concerts where like
Montgomery Gentry would perform and like
Long Island guys would go and Montgomery
Gentry like hose a cowboy you know and
they'd be like
me and they were because they don't
there's no real culture that they
identify what they're just like they
want to be like I'm wide I'm proud of my
family in my faith even though I don't
like my family and I haven't been to
church at some point after all I grew up
like was like you know kid but like
you're part where I grew up
acquired multiple like line dancing bars
yeah this is what it is yeah because it
what else do they have nothing else to
do and the other thing is the Bernie put
the rug and clip out and a lot of people
flipped out you're gonna lose here's the
deal you're gonna lose again you want to
lose you fetishize being a loser and you
want to lose you're putting people
through these purity tests it's gonna
it's gonna bite you Rogen is such an
asset to have and whether I don't even
think it's fair by the way I would be
like it's not fair to put out a clip of
someone as an official endorsement right
if they haven't officially endorsed you
I don't know that they had a
conversation with you or not but my
whole thing is like to get angry yeah
about it is so [ __ ] childish and I
mean I don't know how more progressive
that was the over the years a bunch of
broken stuff and like I don't know how
much more progressive he can be they
want him to cut his dick off yeah I mean
they want him to transition he could be
more progressive in the cut his dick off
on there and became a woman that was he
could be what they're looking for they
want him to saw his [ __ ] off and shove
it and Barry Rice's throat and then and
then that's how he could be more
progressive okay he takes his dick off
and then he throws it and Barry Weiss's
face it goes free Palestine and then it
would be okay to endorse Bernie Sanders
he's had on Abby Martin Kyle kuklinski
Cornel West Bernie Sanders David Pakman
he talked to Matt Taibbi in his three to
four-hour conversations about things
like you know prison industrial complex
Israel and Palestine race inequality all
of those things and you turn on CNN
they've got Richard Spencer stormy
Daniels right Rachel Maddow is [ __ ]
talking about
Putin hiding in a closet and ichigo's
hesitated with Roger Ailes and she
probably puts on a strap-on and [ __ ]
them so let's get real Rachel Maddow and
Roger Ailes have dinner together it's
all fake here the conversation was Milo
vice you know talks to [ __ ] what was
it Cantwell yeah [ __ ] at me for it
right Rachel Maddow it was like close
with Roger Ailes yeah so it's you
professional Rhett it doesn't stop and
that's why people that are like online
or people that get their news from these
I love my dad but here's what happened
to my father's brain it's been rotted
because he's gotten his news from people
like chris matthews and chris matthews
when the whole apps anything happened
chris matthews who is a irish fat
blowhard okay who does nothing but
parrot the party line of anything that's
going on loves washington loves powerful
people is the opposite of a journalist
is it looks like a hunk of Irish soda
bread he's not he's nowhere near Tim
Russert even had some Russert not
perfect about money the press right no
no someone else I don't think Chris
Matthews no Chris Matthews knows that
kind hardball is like ha ha he was
parodied constantly yeah with good
reason when the whole epstein thing
happened this was Chris Matthews hot
tank okay by the way by the way not only
should the Irish not be allowed to speak
publicly they should be chained at all
times to do their physical job okay
Christmas Chris Matthews Chris mean uh
if they just don't lift let's be I'm
sick a line most Irish people excluding
me most Irish people just are not
supposed to think they're supposed to
emote they're supposed to sing they're
supposed to dance and they're supposed
to tell tales but they're not supposed
to like break it down so this was Chris
Matthews response when the FCC things
happened he goes you know a lot of these
politicians end up take because they
egos they become friends with these
nefarious characters because they don't
have a lot of money so they need to fly
places
they're politicians they need to go to
places so they end up forming
relationships with these you know
nefarious characters he's dark and they
don't know what's going on they don't
know how good they know we're gonna wait
in the airport for 10 minutes yeah so
Bill and Hillary Clinton can't afford to
go anywhere should be less the flight
and where do they all need to go the
Virgin Islands where are they going they
got think anything in like a million
dollar speaking fee someone yeah but
again imagine think of the people who
got their news from that system for
years because even the articles written
about I've seen from the mainstream
press like yeah that's a little fishy
right now
the flip side of that is if you go
online you know you know it's we we all
know what online is it's just a [ __ ]
you know it's completely know it
free-for-all with a guy in you know goat
horns just you know sacrificing the
Baphomet it's like there's no there's no
moderation there's no moderation but in
this case this is the one case where
they're mostly right yeah but they're
mostly right yeah it's it but that's the
real problem the real problem is that
our parents got their news and that's
where we have the country we do you eat
poison you get your news from people
that literally should not be allowed to
speak publicly or just handed talking
points unless it should get your news
from these people you eat it Wendy's you
drink you get prescribed all these drugs
and then at the end of everything it's
like yet there's nothing left nothing's
left it's all gone and then you have to
deal with all these massive problems
forty percent of the labor force is
gonna be automated and like our parents
just want to play golf and get a condo
they don't they're like witty what
they're like who gives a [ __ ] what do
you mean 40 percent of Labor for good
they're like that sounds nice like you
tell people that you tell people that
are older than I think a 40% of labor
was gonna be automatic you kids have it
so easy you have no idea how lucky you
are you know you're gonna have hate
waiting on lines in the car wash you
know the labor force they're just it's
they're gonna be all these kids can have
automated you know you know my son told
me you had a Vinny he said forty percent
of the lay before it's gonna be robots
they're gonna be sim pretty these kids
they're gonna be
[ __ ] pretty these guys I mean can you
believe how lucky they are
well that is in some weird way if you
actually like looking the Marx time I
sent her a little Das Kapital but you
know Ray's become a fat Marxist time map
which is somehow living in Brooklyn is
somehow his journey to become like this
fat he went from a fat libertarian to a
fat Marxist because there's two places
you can go from libertarian and you stay
fat but you go to either March or you go
to Nazi but you stay and I argue because
I'm sexy I argue if we can afford health
care and we got 40 diverse health care
you go we're just gonna do it [ __ ] it
I'm gonna March this I just don't care
what happens yeah that's a difference
I'm set I look I have no investment in
literally what happens I non-marxist we
should relook cause you know we talk if
you want to oppose them point is a bit
the idea of it is that as Das Kapital
balanced on his stomach and a public
boss there's a woman sitting next to him
just nursing her baby and you're like
listen that's okay you can let it out
we're all human beings here you can let
it out baby don't worry about it I know
why you're in the position you're in
this man wrote a whole book on it there
is some part of it worse like we're
supposed to get to a point where we can
all just like relax and achieve higher
consciousness Marla told me about this
it's like fully automated luxury
communism which mom was telling me he
was saying it as a joke it made me laugh
or just everyone [ __ ] all day and but
money's fake I don't know so somebody oh
sorry I'm a little message really smart
yes girlfriend's going to canvas for
Bernie Sanders and [ __ ] it where she
going uh New Hampshire we're gonna go we
want to film ourselves canvassing for
Bernie Sanders in Beverly Hills
yeah she's standing outside gates and
screaming I read about yeah give him
back a little bit
have you thought excuse me sir have you
heard Bernie Sanders he's also Jewish
don't you have enough don't you have you
no decency sir at long last have you no
decency
husavik cans
I just think it would be absolutely
hilarious to have the great red comp and
myself canvassing for Bernie Sanders in
Beverly Hills California and being you
know attacked by guard dogs and taste
folks you know me I always try to put
you on to cool stuff it's part of what I
do here on the show it's not all just
comedy and doom and gloom it's you know
an advice podcast for many of you I give
good advice but I also you know put you
on the things that you might like one of
those things is a podcast is called
another bachelor podcast it's 20/20 and
there's a lot going on we're on the
brink of World War three Australia is
engulfed in flames there's an
impeachment trial coming up in the world
is being sucked off it's mana but there
is nothing more important going on right
now that season 24 of ABC's The Bachelor
if you're listening to my podcast you're
obviously a fan of that program and
you're probably tuning in every week but
you're wasting your [ __ ] time if
you're not listening to a Bachelor
companion podcast it's what's done the
best one out there we've talked about it
before is another Bachelor podcast
featuring Nick was kids and frantic
parents
Dylan is Jewish and Pat who's an older
man after hearing the Edward I did last
week Pat as I assumed he might in the
near future attempted to take his own
life while he is independently wealthy
with a child on the way my words called
into question his reason I [ __ ] on these
guys in as a joke and I know that right
because listen they're doing a podcast
about the basher a lot of people do it a
lot of people are successful at it now
if you were a fan of The Bachelor and
you want to listen to a companion
podcast go check their podcast out I
think it's I think it's well worth
checking out I'm gonna be a guest on the
podcast about below deck because I do
have an interest in talking about below
deck I don't have an interest to talk
about The Bachelor I don't know why I
find below deck so interesting it's just
about people who charter yachts whatever
but it's interesting and I think they're
okay with me [ __ ] on them as a joke
I mean one of them might might was upset
about it I think or whatever I mean I
don't know I don't know who any of these
people I will never meet I will never
meet these people in my life like I'll
never I will never meet them ever like
if I'm in a room with these people it's
because I'm meeting someone else that
they are somehow near but like I would
never be in this ain't like unless like
we're in an airport like we'd be in an
airport and we'd bump into each other
but there would there would be no like
meaningful interaction between them
that's not a knock and it's not an
insult the only the only the only
difference between me and them would be
that I'm insanely talented insanely
talented and I spend time with other
insanely talented people that's that's
the only that's it there's no there's no
diff everyone's a human being I respect
everybody but that is differential
that's it nothing else by the way I mean
we're carbon-based life-forms
I mean ball thing but I would give The
Bachelor podcast a shot because why not
why not if you enjoy The Bachelor this
is a show where they have to survive in
the woods naked no that's naked and
afraid okay I've seen that one The
Bachelor is about a bunch of women who
compete for the affections of one man
hang on this I think it would be great
if you were they should do a bachelor
skid-row
yeah where you are the bachelor and then
all the women still choose to go back to
skid row well this woman aren't
unattractive what the woman that's good
ro1 bad at all they weren't bad at all
I could I could see you dating them till
I give them a rose yes you give them a
rose here's the deal
what's the point of being a father if
you know you'll fail what's the point of
doing anything really what's the point
of even sticking around this is about
the guy I guess I killed tried to kill
himself if I talked about him he was
found at a bathtub by his podcast
buddies who resuscitated him with the
news at the ad read I did last week was
it did in fact move the numbers so
people are checking it out so tune in
every week
to another basket podcast on iTunes
YouTube and spotify remember everyone
escapism is the only thing that matters
right now there is nothing you can do to
prevent us from annihilation the only
other thing you can do is find ways to
cope so listen to another Bachelor
podcast or their spin-off show recapping
Bravo's hit series below-deck another
below deck podcast and also available
where you get your podcasts I mean III
you know go check it out I wish these
guys to bet I mean listen I mean you
know yeah here's what it is here's what
it really has no one respects you like
that's what it is well if you're a
producer of a podcast
unless you're Jamie Vernon no one
respects you that's what it is it's just
what it you're replaceable you're I mean
it's not I'm glad you do your job well
but it's it's not really it's just not a
thing
like it's not my plumber was part-time
does my taxes - yeah it's kind of like
that you know I like specialization
where someone specializes in something
like if someone came up to me goes you
in a nice restaurant they go you know
who's cooking in the back Bruce
Springsteen I'd go why why is Bruce
Springsteen making our dinner but maybe
maybe I'm wrong maybe it would be great
it's but not in America Yeah right
I don't know so these podcast producers
right now they're very chatty yeah
they're very chatty because they're
they're sick of being behind the the
scenes well look so because they think
it's a big mistake they think it's a big
mistake that they sit behind the scenes
and other people don't they all think
it's a cruel twist of fate and it's just
that they they should be feel Vaughn
should be producing your podcast that's
what these guys thinking when they go
well they put their head on the pillow
in their manic Minds they think that
they are the reason that CEO is funny
they think they're doing it this is the
result of Occupy Wall Street
your job your job is going to be done by
AI last week so I'm glad you're so his
reality and this is sweet kids and I
don't want anyone to think this is Meg
I'm not trying to be negative no I'm
trying to be yup I appreciate because I
would if Lizzie if you if you listen The
Bachelor watch another Bachelor podcast
when you need to listen to The Bachelor
because just listen to the [ __ ]
podcast okay and I listen I'm not trying
to be a dick to anybody because I love
everyone I think everyone's worthy of at
least life you know what I mean at least
be here on earth but like you know just
make it good like I hope it's a great
podcast and I'm sure it's not that bad
I'm sure it's not that bad but like
that's what it is it's like you're not
gonna get famous by having like you know
a [ __ ] you know like I don't know
like to show less for certain amount of
time then it's over it's a fun podcast
right so it's just fun it's nice that
they're also doing below deck so they're
expanding they're doing like a bunch of
different things you know I'm not sure
this [ __ ] on what you're doing by the
way I'm not sure to [ __ ] on what they're
doing it I respect that people are out
there hustling but like just like don't
just just I think you get it you know
just understand what it is so don't be
offended when I like there's people that
listen to the ad that are offended like
one of the guys got a Fed first of all
if you if you're offended by anything I
say why are you doing anything comedic
Lee sure don't be offended by what I say
if you're a friend about what I say if
you're further I want to say don't do
the ad I don't care it means nothing to
me less than I can't explain to you how
little this means to me to do
legitimately less than nothing um but
don't be offended by because I hope
people do genuinely check out your show
but this isn't real
it's not real so I just want you when
you go to bed every night to know that
it isn't it's not a real thing you're
doing and I don't mean the show isn't
real I don't mean the show isn't real
your show is real I mean your life your
your existence on planet earth isn't
real
it's not real you're an avatar you're an
idea you're an avatar you're a shadow
that's reflected off a lake in the
moonlight but that being said I would
check out the show I'm gonna appear on
their below-deck podcast potentially not
now after this ad but so listen it's
called another bachelor podcast and in
their spin-off show the spin-off show
they're spinning off spinning off if you
like but if you like this you'll love
that this Pinto show is called
below-deck it's another below-deck
podcast they do a podcast about like
fidget spinners maybe yeah they were did
done now so that's it I don't want to
listen again I love everybody I hope
everybody loves me it's all in good fun
it's all a good humor we're all kidding
around don't be offended be like to hear
that anyone's offended by anything I
said in an ad read is is absurd to me
and it's it's really crazy because I
called the kid who has been doing these
reads and he wasn't offended but he's
like yeah one of our the guys was like a
little offended and it's like it's like
well what do you think it is is it my
dream you're doing a bachelor recap
podcast and you're advertising on
another podcast and you're offended
about what the guy said like what do you
think you're doing what world are you
living in where it's there's none of its
real what we're doing isn't real it's
not real if my [ __ ] show which is
great and listened to by people is it
real if Hollywood is it real if the
country isn't real
none of its real it's a simulation if
all of it isn't real how in God's name
is your bachelor recap podcast real how
are you getting upset about it think to
yourself that your metadata on a [ __ ]
aliens iPhone dummy oh that's all I'm
saying
it's it's it's it's more metaphysical
I'm not going at you you simpleton
I'm not going at you what I'm saying is
that it's it's it's you know just enjoy
just enjoy that you're in a unique
period in five years you're not gonna be
making a trillion dollar it's over soon
you're at the end of this now it's
coming to an end
podcasting is gonna end soon I don't
know when it is but it's going to end so
just enjoy what it is while it is don't
get angry about what I say none of it
matters it's all it's all fun none of
its real it's not real the below desk
spinoff podcast where you sit down
earthward
starts what are we to do which episode
did we cover last week did don't we
cover three or four shut up just enjoy
it because one day you're gonna be dead
and no one is gonna care do you know
what I mean
no one is gonna care about your death
nobody no one will remember you no one
will speak kindly of you
no one will value any of your
achievements or accomplishments you'll
just be know how I know that because
when I went to is to Spokane comedy club
there were four hot dogs on the menu and
they were the karlon the prior the
rivers or whatever and these are the
greatest comics that ever lived and they
just became hot dogs okay and you guys
are almost as talented as Pryor okay but
not but like you're like almost there so
just don't be upset that's what I'm
saying it's a fun ad you can keep
running them if you want I hope people
check out the
Podcast if you don't want to run them
that's fine too you know if I ever see a
person obviously will will never speak
I'm kidding again no it's my uh Oh like
we said about my bachelor podcast I
don't like it it makes me upset how am I
gonna go home my wife and kids
then I'm feeding off my bachelor podcast
when this guy's gonna [ __ ] on it you
know what happened Dylan did that
five-second we got a bachelor podcast
that we advertised on the show you know
what this fat [ __ ] did he's [ __ ] on it
trying to make it like it was like
stupidest son can you believe it yeah no
I didn't say nothing about that
below-deck podcast she kind of likes
that one but he didn't like her but so
just again
calm down check it out it's another it's
another bachelor podcast and another
below-deck podcast and who were the
three guys again it's Nick
Dylan and Pat Nick Dylan and Pat I think
Dylan was the one who got mad I don't
think Pat got mad he's the older guy and
Nick didn't get me but I think Dylan got
mad I don't know who is Dylan to look it
up roof find him find him it's not Dylan
roof Dylan roof has a Wikipedia
so let's apologize to Dylan who's it I'm
looking it up isn't he the guy that
worked at Corolla with them it's a
baseball oh boy well didn't we meet him
when we went to Corolla isn't it that
guy Dylan Pete Wren is that him I have
no idea
edit his name out okay yeah yeah yeah
it's Dylan rent but I'll bleep that out
yeah Dylan I mean they can look it up
it's on the podcast bio but you don't
want to make it easy
Dylan wears a dress we're kidding around
doing you know it's a joke it's you
doing a Bachelor podcast can I see him
[Music]
is there another photo of them it's him
there's no photos of him at all I mean
this is Twitter that's it I think right
here yeah he's a Jew huh
that guy's a real Jew guys a real big
Jew face that's what it is you could
call me a Mick face that guy's got a Jew
[ __ ] face you see that for coming
from a mile away you see that we're 16
minutes into this read we're trying to
have fun Dylan Dylan the only chance get
[ __ ] listeners is this [ __ ] high
do you want crack it gives you [ __ ]
about your bachelor party yes unless we
make it [ __ ] interesting okay you
know you're not cleaning Adam Carolla's
toilets because you're a genius oh
you're a lot of bachelor because it's
another bachelor podcast so he's
assuming there's a plethora of these
yeah there's there's ones that are doing
very good I'll tell you how good they're
doing they don't advertise how they
don't want a 20-minute harangue but I'm
serious I I support art and artists and
that's what we do here so if you can be
if you can enjoy that you can be playful
and have fun with it but if you're gonna
be serious about it let's just not do it
and I don't care about the money and I
don't care about anything and I clearly
don't I pissed off you know and said a
lot crazier [ __ ] about a lot more people
who can help me out then it's [ __ ]
nonsense so let's just come to [ __ ]
reality and understand that we're having
a lot of fun with this you know what I
mean this is this is what we're trying
to do we're trying to get you listeners
we're trying to get me listeners still
don't be angry this is it like it's not
the Manhattan Project
it's a feud now though you're starting a
podcast for use your a feud with the
another box of podcast guys
boy here we go ha I mean he's not a few
die I die listen I like Nick he's he's a
he's you know he's a person on earth
that you know I would don't want him to
like die I don't want anyone to die some
people yeah so that's where we're at
with this we want you to check out
another Bachelor podcast with Dylan the
older guy cuz I nailed them when I did
the first three that kind of nailed them
one guy you know and then there's the
other guy this Dylan's got it takes it
way too seriously
and then Nick just probably has fun with
it Dylan's just probably like taking
away to see it and it's just like
Dimmick eternally paranoid joke yeah
exactly exactly so you ought to do it
you know if it's not done right no one's
gonna listen I [ __ ] what are you
imagining a world where you tell you
grandchild oh i had a bachelor podcast i
had a bachelor well i wouldn't be a time
would choose a clay in the pledge slow
i'm trying to get chewy
i have a bachelor party cast that's how
i made them my money my grandfather
worked at the diamond district
I had the podcast about a show called
below death when you saw the bachelor
making out with Dean in the jacuzzi how
do you deconstruct that boy do you think
we've done enough time for this we're at
20 minutes now I mean you get what you
pay for don't you boys you get what you
pay for
I'm kidding about cleaning at him to
crawl as toilet I'm sure you didn't do
that you know again enough it's all that
I do that no you did do it
probably but himself so check out
another bachelor podcast and another
below-deck podcast thank you I feel like
in the Democratic Party of yesteryear
there was a place for guys like us you
know
yeah so was there was a little more
muscle than the country I mean listen
Brian Dennehy was dude that's what
people used to find sexy say yes shut
your fat mouth
Brian Dennehy was a man okay he didn't
go to the gym like a [ __ ] he was a man
he had a gut
he drank beer he ate food and he and he
got in his police car and he and he
protected the women and children and
that turned women on Irish women on it
turned them on it turned women on to see
a man of stature with a little heft
little heft and that was a sex symbol
now because that is now the men that are
attractive now are literally there to
describe them as effeminate it's like
straight men that people consider
attractive I'm a timothy Shalem a is a
feather yeah he is a feather
he is the feather from the beginning of
Forrest Gump they just he just floats
around
he doesn't have sex organs he doesn't
have a sexuality he doesn't exist he's
just a wisp of a hair on his entire body
he's just like this tiny little it makes
Dustin Hoffman little attention call me
by your name should have featured me
that that's what it should have been it
should've been me and call me by your
name I would have sucked off whatever
his name is
I'm a hammer and in and and and I said I
tweeted once a guy Branum I said I said
I should be calling my name because
nobody would ever believe you'd travel
to Italy that was good but that's what
call me by name should have been it
should have been you know but we've
we've we've destroyed the mail we've
destroyed them but we've gone from Brian
Dennehy and people like what's that
guy's name used to date Loni Anderson
Rock Hudson no no Burt Reynolds oh yeah
we went from yeah that's a man of course
he is you went that's right we've went
from Burt Reynolds to Timothy Shalem a
Timothy Shalem a is like he's like oh
he's like a petri dish he's barely alive
I don't cooked he's uncooked it's Joe I
don't know he's uncooked they just took
him out of a pot he's playing Bob Dylan
yeah I look the [ __ ] is going on it's we
it says something so gender 'less yes
Salameh is what Hollywood will be just
aimed Rajan is drone people who have no
gender and they all they look
perpetually like like like children with
the disease we're entering a kind of end
time yes in that like at the end of this
we've never done this before the enzymes
get into this this is new where they
tell us about the Endre [ __ ] about how
he's Hollywood guys won't [ __ ] kids
right but what we're now seeing is is
they're kind of coming to a singularity
where the kids the adults are children
now we're adults or children now we're
going you the body type of a child the
body type of a way feet wink right of a
prepubescent kind of boy with the face
of sort of a man but not really
we're my roles this is what I'm saying
where are my roles where are the roles
for people that have skin problems why
would I go outside does everyone look
like they're one foot out of a coffin
well they ain't spend years in the crack
house but my point is this they would
they be talented if they did they
sucky-suck shall amaze a bad animal
there's a bad actor folks you're he's
bad he's not good no yeah I wash Little
Women
I mean people like God well we get
disgusting man
I watch a little woman we get the screen
art we mean the movie I didn't say that
I didn't say that but I've watched a
little women I like the women cuz you
can imagine put them in a picnic basket
and then open them up and they pop out
is that wrong am i am I technically
representing myself or is my lawyer
present
look I'm just saying I like Lady Bird I
thought I was a fine enough movie I
watch that screen with brother girl word
present and I actually you know bumped
into her while trying to get some wine I
think I knocked her over a little bit
but that's not important point is I'm a
not fan but yeah I went into it with
open arms I wasn't like you know because
there's a narrative that when I won't
win
everyone's aware of it but the New York
Times though some people have lives yeah
I'm sorry well beyond but we have a
problem of men watching with a women
right like we're like basically men
aren't interested in watching no they
don't want to see address missus bobbitt
it's a [ __ ] children's book from the
Civil War right these middle-class white
women who like I'll get married but they
end up getting married I mean the movie
was terrible right and uh he was he was
all he's in it he's playing which woman
is he I forget his characters God yeah
Shalem a if he's watching weren't very
good wasn't a fan but the whole thing
was very flat and dry but that's what it
is all on the same run it's all the same
[ __ ] man you got that you think you're
better than me you think you're better
than me now I know that you have all
kinds of people and whatever and I don't
care we are we're its same thing this is
Little Women this is the Godfather now
you can look at a morgue this is this is
it now because of Technology this is
this is it this is rocky you want to
fight me he'll beat the [ __ ] out of you
I would love to see Timothy sha'lame
beat the [ __ ] out of Raycom I would love
to see Timothy Shalem ages [ __ ] house
you know look I know how to use my
weight to my advantage I would just love
to see him beat the [ __ ] that don't - I
would like to see you wrap them up if he
[ __ ] hit some probably would like to
see Timothy sha'lame will the pressure
point thing on you and you just drive -
it I don't know wait some kid in the 70s
watching a Bruce Lee film the fists of
death on you know I'm just saying
there's ways to put you on the ground
not for a child versus a grown fat man
okay well we'll see there's one things
really it's like it offers air Xiaomei
except the fight you bet you got to
light you bet throw the first punch
don't bring your bodyguard unless you
look upon that Staples Center rake up
fights a homeless woman at we're
starting at a small bar we're gonna see
if we can fill that cell 30 tickets I
think we can but my point is that is he
a good act what I say he's a bad actor I
not impressed what am I wrong no look
you want is a good at maybe a younger
actor who you think is good shy as gray
Sharla buff is great cuz he's mentally
ill yeah I mean a young anymore yeah but
uh who's great who's I see in recent
memory they could that kid from did you
see how the the killing of a sacred deer
now that kids weird good like he's
interesting I had I don't know the Irish
guy is famous clarity Colin Farrell
Farrell Colin Farrell um other what else
came out this year young people in their
twenties I'm trying to think I love it
every agent probably tells her Irish
actor don't ever say anything that's not
written on its script right if anyone
asks you anything the way you feel about
anything just don't tell them right
don't ever say anything if you're ever
somewhere and someone puts a microphone
in your face and wants you to comment on
anything please don't write thank you
well it was big this year the big movie
this year and we remember we just
totally don't have a lot of block people
in Ireland it's what I'm saying and I
mean it's just kind of nice living with
people that look like you that's all I
don't plus a problem can you play
spider-man it's not a complex role but
much more charming in chellamay yeah Tom
Holland Tom Holland Tom Holland into
more things I mean the little women what
Tom house a little skinny guy I'm not
saying but people would look like me end
up again and now that's why this me I am
I am
no but it's a better movie listen little
women with you is a better movie it
would be more interesting it's a better
movie to put a fat bearded pig in a bath
in a little hot what do they live in a
little civil war cottage or some nice
house living in a nice house and then
you have this and it's little women
hello Joe I've come to court you yeah
hello I've come for court you I brought
some warm butter would you would you
like to sit on the porch with me while I
regalia or some towel from the war oh
there you go we're fighting to free the
slave I gotta fly
the time when I freed him before the war
technically he still does some work for
me and my family I like him very much
Joe would you make love to me now under
the Starlight I mean it's a better film
I'm picturing it immediately you are in
like a like a like a sucker no you're in
like the whatever the war uniform of the
Union Army Ian Jack yeah you're in the
Union janya and you just and you're
sitting there on the porch pressing on
my scene yeah bursting out of your seat
Joe is sitting there she's unhappy and
you're like Joe I've been thinking of
you doing many along that in the field
do you think you'll ever get to cook as
good as your mother Joe your mother such
a good cook I love her sausage biscuits
this meat is very tender
I like tender meat Joe that's one thing
you should know about Raymond I like
tender meat and free slaves those are my
two favorite things
but he's mighty was shot me show me no
hate on you saw me lying out we're boys
I love you you're my friend let's get
some pokey I gotta remember that I'm in
Hollywood now I mean any time I could
become best friends with any of these
people so I'm just kidding I do the
shallow man if you wanna hang out let's
hang out I'm kidding I'm joking
no yeah it's a joke Billy Eilish if you
want you're actually if you wanna hang
out with me and go drink blood by the LA
River or whatever you do I will do it
with you I will do it I can be a backup
dancer if you want to go to Winchell's
and eat doughnuts Billy let's do you see
a lot of famous people eating Donuts
around here cut not really cauldre's
fascinated by the homeless doughnut
culture yeah there's something that you
we need to take you to a late maybe
tonight we'll take you late-night
doughnut shop sure because you really
really you you you you comment on yum
yum donuts and you notice Winchell
you've noticed a lot of the doughnut
shops the my donut shop is just
something that we have plenty of Dunkin
Donuts but it ever feels like the Dunkin
Donuts or like the jalapenos
little bit about the donut shop no
obviously Mexican people love sugar they
left what are they call it panda loose
whatever it is yeah yeah handily they
love sugar and they love the sweets and
that's just what it is it's not racism
it's what it [ __ ] it is and they work
very long hours and they need coffee and
sweets and that's what the game is I
also like sweets and coz so [ __ ] off
okay don't hit me up you are Mexican art
you don't like that well then you see
you're one of the ones that suck so but
tell us a little bit about the total
culture because you know about it
because you're you've spent la around
slugs like you kind of know and I don't
mean Maxim's of slugs I mean donut shops
that are open all night are not always
attended Mexicans go in the morning
because then they go to work hmm so what
is it about the donut shops do do do a
little well I'm glad you didn't make me
say the Mexican thing on my own but you
said not racist you say Mexicans like
sugar no they're up at 4:00 in the
morning they need their sugar and their
caffeine to get going crap it is what it
is correct but there's some iconic
places we might take you to donut Prince
I think yeah up in Burbank by the safari
in like this a little bit King Prince I
mean when you get there it's not really
what I conic about donut Prince I know
Tom Green you still like periscope and
like March down there and people would
like follow him down the street okay wow
that's kind of that's kind of light in
terms of the ionic but like that in
bob's big boy are two kind of iconic
places yeah yeah yeah or any of the
doughnuts in any news place is good
that's not a question really no not
really
we'll go to Koreatown we'll go to
California donuts maybe after this is
that good I think it's okay I think it's
pretty good California donuts
I think Krispy Kreme freeze California
Raisins yeah I just love member the
California rays they're the best I know
my mother loved them what was the deal
with the California raisin with
claymation raisin antropomorphic raisins
that would they were perfect some have I
guess Motown band that were they would
sing like by the way this gets very
racist and we have nothing to do with
that no it was just they had no we did
not make raisins black people right look
is that what it is I don't know that
they were fine California rains
I know I look if I watched again now it
might not work I'm sure it's very late
saying this no one's brought it up in a
while
Motown was up with a predominately black
genre music listen of course I'm just
saying I don't know why the raisins are
black I'm just saying it's almost like
people were like hey maybe we should
just help cuz they're black but you like
raisins like that's what I feel like the
executives like the people were behind
this for like hey you like raisins yeah
we stole black people's voices and
talent and gave it to raisins that we
created yeah I think you're right so we
don't have to pay black people that's
what I think it might be I don't know
I'm just guessing whether all this
diversity in Hollywood
I love that it's excluded platelet black
people who are some of the most
naturally talented people ever you know
what I mean but we have to watch you
know romances it's like it said I loved
it it just doesn't get the black people
it's like Muslims Asian people are
transgender sri lankans but it will
never be black like it's like that's how
racist Hollywood is if there's not black
people anyone else
they'll be alien felt there'll be films
with aliens in them before they [ __ ]
get but it's just how racist Hollywood
really is they really just it's insanely
racist it's gross and they're like
they're like yeah we'll give you a
little you get here's a little uh a
little Aquafina
a little Rami Yusef and that's it and
they'll they'll do shows you have a
sassy black friend who will come in and
be like you look good and that'll be it
instead you know which it's just wild
that that particular discrimination
doesn't seem to end yeah I mean you get
the people will chime in uh you know
about yeah great and they're all great
yeah that's the thing it's like they're
great it's like a lot of black people do
think it's actually really good and they
used to be a lot more but then we went
in the last few years they found unfunny
black people which is almost impossible
like Hollywood's went and found just
unfunny black me it's like I don't even
know how you found
unfunny black women they've been through
more than anyone else in the country and
they're genuinely
hilarious and they're and they're tough
and their gritty
they've been through [ __ ] which is where
humor comes from real humor and how
you've liked found unfun it's like wild
there's a level of like you know it's
replacing to so many racist stereotypes
everything's got to make white people
feel comfortable exactly everything's
got to be cuddly it's gotta be cuddly
for white people you know it's like
they'll make a move they'll make a movie
where it'll be it'll be about like the
Civil War and it'll be about like robert
e lee's wife having like second thoughts
because she met a black person and the
whole movie will be a hero arc about
robert e lee's wife you know and then
she'll be like i really changed my fault
a piece of still love Robert but I
realize now and they'll be like what
abuse a beautiful film that piece of
[ __ ] that when the Academy Awards book
yeah and it's like you want i watch some
of it is like video Morgan explain Fried
Chicken to like it's just like you ever
had fried shoes and like I don't look
it's just based on a true story because
like the idea that it would be some kind
of racist stereotype that heats ate some
fried chicken in his life no this means
educated and talented so he's never had
fried chicken like it's some crime for
some guy who's a clogged up my things a
penis never know he would have eaten
fried chicken look will you do it what
even is this but I just love that that's
the version it's like it's the white
Savior you know a movie about one of the
most heroic women in history robert e
lee's wife she learns about racism from
like you know she has like a chance
encounter you know I understand that
Robert was fighting for the world he
knew oh I have to fight for the new
world Donna I know climates are going
you sure you want to do this yeah yeah
yeah just checking all right Rob well I
understand that the world is complex and
then you know like Charlize Theron will
play the black friend
[Laughter]
be like hey [ __ ] and she'll be using
like like 20th century like verbiage
yeah yeah yeah should be like you
changing your you really changing your
views and I'm here for it I'm here for
it to be like great job Charlie's a
South African and I'm not one of these
people that he thinks that like you know
I'm not with these people that's like
always an Asian thing it always has to
be in it like but I just think it is
kind of like to me there was nothing fun
somebody said that they were gonna have
Julie Roberts play Harriet Tubman
there's nothing like years ago they
thought it was really there was really
gonna try there's nothing funnier than
that conversation ooh what happened
right you knew in somewhere in the 90s
that conversation happened when
executives like we're gonna give it to
the biggest star in the country Julia
Roberts I don't care who it's about what
did you see and I'm not a cultural
appropriation guy at all I don't give a
[ __ ] it's whatever but did you see
sometimes it's so funny
they gave white models on a runway show
dreads and blonde dreads and black
dreads and it looks so wildly
inappropriate so they all look like they
were guys we need like from your project
yeah but it's like they were wearing
these like Egyptian headdresses with
like yeah dreads and it's just so funny
to me too by the way people in fashion
are all insane oh god they're all insane
so it's just funny when they parade that
insanity on a runway and then you just
look at it you go not only is he
unappealing visually it's just insane in
this climate
I mean you weep for years now it's been
like they're so far behind the curve
right last year they had that thing with
Johnny Depp where he was basically doing
like it was some kind of Native American
ship he was like it was some perfume for
like now or whatever but like it was the
native experience but as told by Johnny
Depp who the guy who played Tonto in the
Lone Ranger
yeah nobody knows Native Americans
better than Johnny Depp Hey it's just so
funny to me that there's people there I
mean it is like Gucci
every now and then they'll be like you
know Gucci like gucci prison and they'll
have like you know orange outfits it's a
Gucci jumper by the way they will start
closing down prisons and then they'll
turn them into themed resorts where
white chicks will take selfies and
they'll be like having the brunch in the
execution room like Alcatraz I'm sure
they do but it'll be like resorts where
they'll stay like they'll stay in the
cell door will slam and they'll be like
it's time for mimosas you know I'll see
on the yard [ __ ] they're gonna be on
the yard like it's gonna happen it's
just what's gonna happen can't do
anything about it
just enjoy it just enjoy it
closing thoughts Raymond this is again I
want to explain this to everybody
because I know that we're gonna get a
lot of comments that you don't like the
studio or you don't or you think there's
lots of things that are not up yet an
evolving thing I mean the life the back
life for instance needs to be up higher
a little bit like you don't think we
know technical help us if you want if
you hold the person will check him out
help us
we just said to them to all shut the
[ __ ] up and now and now you're trying to
help do none of these people are gonna
help us in a positive way is now us
hey don't help us what we're saying is
the Lighting's gonna get better we're
gonna put stuff up here it's gonna look
cool we're playing around with things
this is a process it's not something
that happens overnight this will take a
little bit of time to get it exactly
where we want it and you know if you
want it to happen quicker stop listening
to the other podcasts start listening to
mine start subscribing to the patreon
start doing all these things
so that we can get higher numbers so
that we can get [ __ ] a nice chunk of
money so that we can get a big beautiful
studio like everybody else and fun and
this is beautiful I mean it is going to
be very nice we're trying something a
little different here we want it to be a
little dark we don't want you know a
traditional studio we want something
different you gotta break a few omelets
to make an egg that's not at all in
that's not right break through almost
American egg yeah listen to me
this for me gotta break a few hands to
make an egg that's what my father used
to say break a head and you get an
omelet sometimes uh where can they find
you you're on the patreon a lot people
that are like oh ray is not on the chef
ray lives in New York I live in
California
Ray's on the patreon a lot I always try
to get around the patreon because it's a
great show with you on I love doing the
show solo - I'm gonna broadcast in
podcast more there's always room for you
to be on the show there's gonna be
enough podcasting for me to do solo some
people love and you're on some people
love what I'm just yelling by myself
there's ample there's look there wasn't
you're a little great they're all here
there's enough of everything right
there's really enough of everything for
you to enjoy something you [ __ ] ever
enough for you [ __ ] people this might
be a transition time in two years you
might look back we have a whole podcast
network I'm living in LA we don't know
yes right about the time podcasting ends
in two hitters we'll have a network
don't worry folks and then we're all
gonna get on MySpace cuz it is a bubble
and it's all crashing down okay no this
folks most podcasters are enjoying
success right now will die horribly if
history is any indication of what
happens it's just what's gonna happen
well it doesn't mean that I'm happy
about it so you can follow me at rake um
Instagram and Twitter
the [ __ ] podcast is realized here's
another thing most people don't know
this you are you are fighting Brendan
Schaub
this is a huge thing yeah just been
announced Ram Brendan Schaub
are fighting because now he was a
professional fighter but you used to run
what five miles a day
I used to run five miles a day I'm
willing to bite I'm not sure if he's
used to biting people when he fights in
China so yeah what is your strategy cuz
he could kill all three of us yeah
easily
so he walks in the room right now he's
gonna fight you what is your strategy
the strategy ever had to in my book I'm
not looking to pick a fight but if I had
if he's gonna push me in the limit no
good I like that you're ready on war
footing he's gonna push you to the limit
yeah you know I'm gonna wrap him up as
much as I can now playing with that is
to everyone wrap him up you're gonna
wrap him up now mom
getting close look I'm not gonna do
anything striking I'm not gonna be I'm
gonna I'll punch the guy right
interesting
so thanks for clarifying the only shot I
have is to kind of use my body weight
against him as much as I can
he's not used to fighting guys my weight
all right no one is maybe guys in the
prison is it possible that he punches
you and loses his hand in you yeah look
he might not be used to I'm insulated
more than some of like if he punched you
and he went like elbow length inside of
you runs you then kind of just I go yeah
I'm big in his eyes I'm gonna you know
bite by his mouth you're gonna bite its
mouth yeah it's soft so you tickets for
that our love is disgusting n come come
B's kind of a little bit of stuff
relaunch this week we're gonna come back
with more from our regular episodes and
uh transition that you know twice a week
probably do a little paint more patreon
stuff so revisit come revisit our love
is disgusting what I do at Lucy Steiner
from you know she's hilarious I'm it's
great podcast and uh yeah a trach
complex where Instagram Tim J Dilla di
ll one Tim Jay Dylan di ll o N on
Instagram Twitter
I'm a launching a door and it's going to
be maybe not launched by the time this
episode comes out if you [ __ ] heard
it here you heard it here first it might
be launched I'm not announcing the name
yet but we're launching a tour we're
gonna be in like well over 30 markets in
2020 in terms of weekends tickets gonna
be available on Tim Dylan comedy calm
really excited about that
patreon the Tim Dylan show you get an
extra episode every week for five
dollars for twenty dollars you get an
extra episode every week plus an extra
episode monthly we're doing video now in
the studio four times a month every week
this is going to be we're gonna be
committed to that it's gonna be an
entirely different experience
visually we're gonna really work on this
we're gonna we're gonna cover the tables
I mean again this is real rough stuff
it's real [ __ ] DIY
you're getting in here you're in on the
basement level and the elevator is only
going up to paddock suite you see what I
mean kids so I I mean this is really
where it's at
so grab tickets I will be at Zanies in
Chicago from the 5th through the 8th
Justin out Charlotte North Carolina this
comes out Sunday I've already done well
know it comes out this Sunday so if
you're in [ __ ] Charlotte North
Carolina or you know someone who is I'm
going to the comedy Zone in Charlotte I
love that Club I'm gonna be there
January 29 30th 31st I'm heading in New
York City to do my favorite [ __ ]
Super Bowl party Sal Vulcano and
practical joker does amazing Super Bowl
party and then I go to Zanies in Chicago
from the 5th through the 8th I'm at
Zanies in Chicago grab tickets for that
then I am at the grand Jerrod Theatre in
Toronto Valentine's Day the 12th 13th
14th in Toronto [ __ ] amazing there's
many more dates a whole tour is coming
we're really excited about it I've got a
new hour material we're getting ready
we're gonna we're gonna really get it
out there for the next six months and
maybe shoot it put out a special or
whatever and you know whatever catch me
on Spade show that's a funny show that I
enjoy doing but subscribe to the YouTube
channel the Tim Dylan shell subscribe
rate the podcast five stars give us a
positive review on Apple podcast listen
on Spotify if you want get our numbers
up on Spotify if that's where you get
your podcast listen to the Tim Dylan
show on Spotify Google podcasts whatever
we are everywhere
okay you should be - closing thoughts
[Music]
it's all coming down Road it you got it
when you went correct just leave it at
that
just leave it at that don't try that
don't try to follow what was just
brilliant thank you very much and listen
let me endorse because I want to help
people - let me give my presidential
endorsement and my presidential
endorsement is for Dick Cheney so I will
I think Cheney is the only guy right now
that has the gravitas don't you love
when they used to describe politicians
that the bakery has gravitas you know
which means he he will murder people
Nixon had Robert
that's what gravitas we grab with us
means he will uh chew on a pork chop
while while countries are getting
carpet-bombed gravitas that's a guy with
gravity mister hello gravitas
he has gravitas he doesn't let a
genocide upset his meal he's got
gravitas why don't you get some gravitas
and also and this is not a joke and
we're just very quickly we are releasing
a line of jewelry exclusive jewelry by
podcaster Tim Dylan you know that I've
been passionate you know one thing about
me is I've always been passionate about
jewelry oh yeah no you watches rings I
love jewelry it's something that I've
loved my entire life in my growing up
with my parents and my mother loved
jewelry and my father loved ruie and
there was something special about
there's something special about having a
nice Rock sure people also know about me
that I love creating opportunities for
people but you know that about me you
you you're a giver I give what I want to
give people is an opportunity to share
my love of jewelry with strangers yes
for a profit because I want to create a
pathway to a better life using something
that I love talk about a time in your
life where my love of jewelry has helped
you I remember where I I thought I had
this regular cancer at one point yes
that was a tough time and I do I got the
urologist I was waiting for my sonogram
results back and you were just calming
me down banging on a table with this
beautiful topaz ring yes he was banging
saying can you shut the [ __ ] up you fat
idiot but the ring it was it was a
calming presence there he's like you
don't have ball cancer you fat [ __ ] but
like the tapping of the ring not doing
it on the table I described it enough
stop touching the table right but what
it was was a perfectly set stone no it
was a perfectly set stone and what I've
realized about jewelry
is that it is the constant it is a thing
that doesn't go away people die you know
what I mean sure the earth will die but
good jewelry a perfectly set stop will
last forever I'm asking people to go out
into their communities door-to-door and
knock on people's doors and then when
people open those doors I want them to
tell a story that you just told and I
want them to say would you like to see
an exclusive opportunity from from Jules
with this one it's called Jules bye
podcaster Tim Dylan right that's rolls
off the tongue but a lot of people don't
know how to create those opportunities
so we're having a sales seminar yeah in
the Arizona Marriott and it's going to
be
$7,300 it's going to be three days
success ain't for you
never is and what will it will it will
teach strategies to not only because
it's not only about selling the jewelry
it's about understanding the product
falling in love with the product and
understanding why the product is needed
right there's gonna be a real
come-to-jesus moment for a lot of you
many of you don't you don't know many
people that leave the seminar had left
similar last year they asked me to pay
more right they said I give you more
money
and I said no yeah I said don't do it
give it to your children and they cried
and the amount of weeping I witnessed
during that weekend and then we're not
in desperation but just like their lives
were changed they realized they could
feed their families they could get that
boat people were coming up to me after
the seminar and saying my life had
literally no purpose I mean literally I
I would sit in a stoplight and go there
is no reason I just don't drive in the
oncoming traffic and close my eyes until
I started selling jewelry for you
right a woman asked me feel this feel my
took my thumb and she put it on arrest
this is where I tried to slit my wrists
right for right I couldn't even do that
right these are the scars and now she's
making
words of a lot of tens of hundreds of
dollars don't even tell them because
it's it's you know what it is it's not
about the money it's about the feeling
you got when you've you've put the
perfect jewel the perfect stone with the
perfect person that feeling and yes are
people necessarily susceptible to this
all the time no because it is a hard
sell because we're asking you to go
toward a door we were asking you to go
door to door because because there's a
lot of federal gov there's a lot of
state governments and local townships I
don't want you to succeed they do not
want you to succeed and they do not they
do not allow us to market effectively on
the phone because because they are
afraid they are fresh
regularly the rats all the quarries
they're all owned by the government
listen we don't need to get into this
but this is real you know look into it
all I'm saying is this so I need we need
so what needs to happen it's you need to
get gorillas out there and you need to
you need to just be able to go door to
door and and actually catch people I
don't want to say off guard but I would
have surprised people I don't scare them
but here's what I will say is anything
good in life does it ever happen if
you're not a little scared you got put
the fear of Jesus in them they need to
know that that you got to create a sense
of urgency because many people are just
watching their lives go by and if you
knock on their door with with a perfect
opportunity for them yeah it's much
better and because we are prevented from
reaching them on the phone and right now
in most states on the internet and
because we are unable to reach them that
way we're going old school because I
love face-to-face right I like to sit
down with someone face-to-face and you
can another thing is you have parties in
your house you bring your friends over
this is not a Ponzi scheme many people
who've been threatened by our success of
called it a Ponzi scheme and whoever
these people are how many look a lot of
these things
there they want you to buy the Mirza we
want you to sell what is a hard there's
a question what is a Ponzi scheme even
mean what does it even mean it doesn't
mean anything
vaporware people are upset with us
because we want to empower you that's it
and drools by podcaster Tim Dylan
enables you to become independent from
government assistance from the
assistance of your family you're going
to be able to get that car get that
apartment turn around I've had people
come to me years later and say the
catalyst for me to change my life the
catalyst was was it was an emerald that
you showed me in Flagstaff Arizona at a
Hilton well because they said I looked
at the jewel and I became so listen so
again I don't we're not gonna use
belabor the point here I'm just saying
this is real it's not a bit it's not
like a bit on the show I want to help
people but you wanna help people you man
enough to take it or woman enough or not
buying it we have a lot of non-binary
you're generous enough that we have knew
what you need to do Tara now if I told
you how many non-binary people we're
making millions of dollars selling my
jewels you'd lose your [ __ ] mind
you'd lose your [ __ ] mind
okay so jewels by podcasters until we're
setting up an exclusive website we are
gonna set this out and we are going to
do a seminar I really want to do a
seminar I think we could really in
Arizona and I genuinely want to do a
seminar see who comes come to come to it
it's got to be in a hotel in Arizona and
I want to do a seminar and we want to
talk about because the jewelry business
has changed it's like anything else yeah
what are some of the large changes
you've seen in the jewelry business this
book there's a lot of these chain stores
they're coming in and these certificates
of authenticity really they're kind of
poisoning the well
they're missing the point this where did
it come from it's like free was I even
mean it's missing the point
everything in life is conflict what is
the stone where is it who they we're
getting ahead of ourselves
are you happy does it make you happy
what do you see when you look at that
[Laughter]
the sparkle it's sparkling you tell me
doesn't sparkle ma'am ma'am look will
let your finger your finger do you know
some of the unhappiness is some of the
people that I know that live in misery
you know what they do they ask did you
know they spend their whole life doing
asking questions they ask questions they
just go what why who where who what why
where it's like enough
just let so that's an important change
now is them we're facing a lot of things
in the marketplace and one of them is
consumers that are demanding
unreasonable things from us it's the
classic case of we go to a doctor and
you're going WebMD and you're trying to
diagnose your son yes you're not yeah
you think you know you don't know we
spent years there were decades people
want Authority yeah
people want authority figures people
want people to speak with authority and
people want people to take their hand
and say you close your eyes and I walk
you through right I walk you through you
don't need to I people like taking
remember that quote when there was one
foot set of footprints in the sand it's
because that Jesus carried you right let
us carry you close your eyes close your
eyes and love them for you let jewels
let jewels start selling jewels by
podcaster Tim Dylan I'm telling it'll
change your life
so Tim Dilla comedy calm which is again
I'm a comedian as a side business but
I've done a lot of great things for a
lot of people I'm not ashamed of it I
should be ashamed that I helped so many
people it's wild isn't it crazy to be
ashamed of helping others you know why I
was ashamed because I thought I would go
my god
and that because I'd help so many people
I thought I was God and that's why I was
ashamed because of course I'm not I'm
not technically God what is God correct
but the amount of people had helped it
was starting to get who's getting tricky
right cuz it was like I'm not a human
being like I've done I've brought so
much love into the lives of people you
know what I mean I've never seen the
footprint the impact yes of one man
touched so many bank accounts yes and we
would demonize money now Bernie Sanders
right and the other one when affairs
wants you to be poor so he could help
you and the other one you know Acacio
Cortez right whose grandfather was was
Hernan Cortez the Explorer who
discovered chocolate and their
multi-millionaire look grant you
narration you know Cortez he was quote
you didn't eat wasn't your mind
exploring yeah I think was a little
older my point is if she's from a mind
family and sacrificed children on a hill
he wasn't my who was he then he was
Spanish for Portuguese maybe my point is
this okay
who's she to take your money who is she
look she's gonna take it and she's gonna
we're gonna multiply it here's what she
doesn't want you to be she doesn't want
you to be educated she doesn't want you
to have your own thriving door-to-door
jewelry because her slob that she needs
to she the exit you can't put a watch on
someone and change their [ __ ] life
take their wrists take it you know and
that when cuz you you weren't a great
sales when I first hired you what
changed what made you because then you
started really closing deals and I think
runs because they're correct me if I'm
wrong I think it was because early on
you didn't submit to the program
immediately right you were a little
skeptical like many people that are
listening to this right now they're
skeptical but then eventually I think
and correct me if I'm wrong but you
basically started started really
applying the rules and doing and doing
the work is this true
no I would second-guess you I would I
would say why would this work I
be willing to go to the links you wanted
me to go to right I would take no for an
answer
I would you not use my presence and my
physicality as a tool which is important
right because a lot of people need to
feel that this is an important moment in
their life if your life is not in danger
how are you gonna use when you stand in
someone's doorway let's just say it this
way when you stand in someone's doorway
they need to know you're there and when
you say to them I have a unique
opportunity from podcaster Tim Dylan
people go I can't afford jewelry go
listen that's a common misconception but
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna sit down
with you in your living room at your
kitchen table we're gonna drink a cup of
coffee I don't mind if it's not the
fancy stuff that's a good line I use
that I don't mind if it's not the fancy
stuff shank is fine for me and then if
they don't have coffee I said it's
nothing wrong with water and then sin
many of the places we sell this there is
a lot wrong with water and so you
shouldn't have anything but what I still
do is I sit down at their kitchen table
with them and something the last time I
did this to a woman offered me cereals
because I didn't have any milk and we
ate dry cereal together and I still made
her understand how important it was for
her that I walked out of there with a
commitment I made a woman cooking eggs
once yeah and she was happy to do it
I mean I didn't make her I insisted and
she understood that those two eggs that
really cost nothing what's an egg is
sand each that that will open the window
to a new life for her wish where's she
now right she's past and that's and but
you know what she was doing well for a
while and you know what and I'm sure
that her family's not scrambling to get
funeral much she said a better life for
her family covered a lot of expenses
we'll leave it that yeah we have we have
we have testimonials we'll read on the
next episode children are happy this is
what it is folks my name is Tim Dillon I
sell jewelry I'm a podcaster but that's
not what excites me what excites me is
creating opportunities because I believe
everyone's country's an entrepreneur my
cousin
has Down syndrome and most people think
he would not be a good jewelry salesman
if I showed you the amount of true
jewels that he sold you would be shocked
the smartest men I know well because
he's one of the smartest people I've
ever met in my life and he's gonna make
him a vice-president of the partner of
this and I don't know what the corporate
structure is but I'm gonna put him put
his name on the accounts and he is I
mean he's amazing and we love him and we
love him and we love his little hands he
sometimes but that look he does what he
asked to do it's all love it's not
coming from anything else but love so if
he touches you he loves you I'm not
complaining I'm not afraid of love and I
think a lot of you people are afraid of
money I'm not afraid of money I'm not
afraid of helping okay so thank you
everybody and good luck out there we'll
have details about the seminar and you
know like I said at the end of the day
and this is really the quote that I've
that I've really lived my whole life by
at the end of the day stop asking
questions no it's the end of the day
that's the that's the end of the quote
why do are you gesturing to me no I was
you saying that's it you were looking at
me late or something else coming see the
ponies at the end of the day I was I was
content at the end of the day that's
what you tell people at the end of the
day do you understand what I'm saying I
look like and I'd lived a message live
the message alright the end of the day
the end of the day the end of the day
live the message at the end of the day
good night